you guys are doing great Oh get that
booty Miley Cyrus is enjoying the single
life and all the family time leh mom as
we all know it's been a whirlwind few
months for Miley shortly after she and
Liam Hemsworth called it quits she began
spending time with Caitlin Carter but
they too have gone their separate ways
and now et is all sorts of details on
what's been going on a source tells E
team Miley thought things with Caitlin
moved far too quickly and that Miley was
the one to end things with Caitlin our
source says Miley leaned on Caitlin
through her divorce with Liam and dad's
quote Miley wasn't thinking long-term
and when Caitlin realized Miley was done
it was a total shock Miley has been all
about the gram lately though posting
this seemingly in reference to her split
or splits writing quote goodbyes are
never easy but got to go
Miley has been at a resort in Utah with
her sister Brandi and her mom Tish and
we've been getting all sorts of updates
from them
they've been hiking spending time with
their pups spending time at the pool
paddle boating but Miley made headlines
for posting this to herstory quote my
mom called this disgusting there was a
gorgeous sunset and I was inside on my
phone serving content
I mean hilarious but it doesn't stop
there she adds quote it's hard to get in
trouble once you're an adult but she
said I looked like a bratty millennial
which I do but is it bad if I like the
pic and want to post is that the worst
Tish Cyrus Miley it's not the worst but
after that story went everywhere Miley
seemingly poked fun at the whole thing
posting this quote my mom is the love of
my life forever
hugger always good and don't expect
Miley's family time to end
time soon our source says she's leaning
on her family now and is doing really
well alright guys that is it for today
for all the latest on Miley stick with
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]